yesterday the pioneer woman helped to
win a continent today with the same
spirit of determination American women
are working to save this way of life
working to save the nation from the
impact of total war working to build a
sure defense
American women are alert to the dangers
which threaten our democracy today women
trained in science are testing and
observing and working to discover new
ways to meet this threat other women
skilled and unskilled are asking what
can I do to help this film will show
what women are doing and what they can
do every woman has an important place in
the national defense program in science
in industry and in the home
silk is vital to national defense it's
most important use is for parachutes and
powder bags new substitutes are being
perfected in the laboratory to meet the
growing demand normal wear is hard on
clothes but not so hard as a machine
like this and there is a direct relation
between an abrasion tester clothing and
National Defense durability and economy
are important to American consumers
called on to make sacrifices in this
emergency
defense is more than military equipment
and armed forces defense is keeping the
nation strong and healthy in this
important work of defense our scientists
are experimenting with small animals to
find out things about vitamins a
complete report of their reaction and
growth is recorded after they are given
experimental food formulas during which
they are carefully checked and weighed
new and health giving diets are being
developed through this research
this woman is a modern pioneer a
scientist she symbolizes the
tremendously important work of women in
chemistry in bacteriology in physics in
nutrition in medicine in hundreds of
hospitals and laboratories throughout
our country men and women who work on
the production of our defense weapons
must be well nourished good nutrition is
not entirely a question of income
thousands of women are attending free
lectures on how to buy food and prepare
meals which are nutritious and
economical
women working in industrial plants need
costumes which are comfortable and safe
around machinery uniforms which meet
these needs have been designed
two-thirds of the jobs in defense
industries can be done by women today
and officials of the defense program are
advocating more extensive job training
for women and girls these bills already
trained in our new defense program are
able to turn out small machine parts
more women are being trained in
mechanical trades to meet the shortage
of skilled labor but drilled presses
turret lathe milling machines planos and
welding equipment women are being
recruited daily to help make planes for
the nation's air forces 3 million women
in factories all over the country are
making things sewing strong fabrics so
in control surfaces for our fighter
planes in a war in which so many
machines and tools and so much metal is
required it is strange how much sewing
there is women are bringing a natural
skill to an important job their official
contribution is helping us to speed up
production of bombers and fighting ships
one parachute takes 65 yards of silk
only silk has the lightness and strength
essential in making parachutes women who
have had special training in the
manufacture of this product are the only
ones who can be employed in these
factories a man's life depends on every
parachute so there is no margin for
error the nimble fingers of these women
are capable of turning out perfect
workmanship on unbelievably fast running
machines
these highly specialized industries are
finding women extraordinarily efficient
and are using them more and more in the
making of precision instruments which
are so essential in war today all of
these instruments require ball bearings
or roller bearings bearing so precise
that experts must use a microscope for
assembly this is work in which women
Excel giving it constant care and
alertness women's hands thousands of
them skillful patient and accurate are
assembling parts precisely dimension
without which no bomber could fly and
without which no mechanised land unit
could move
every ship that glides down the ways
must have electrical switches women
today are assembling gauging fitting
together riveting drilling and making
them this work requires fingers that
move with lightning speed every defense
worker doing her job well that's the
Battle of production and the essence of
defense
women are working side by side with men
on the assembly lines and in inspection
units of munition factories millions of
shells are moving off the production
lines in our great plans from coast to
coast shells for tanks and naval guns
shells for colston field artillery
shells for anti-aircraft defense women
are skillful engaging and checking for
my Newton perfections mass production is
important when you realize that a single
machine gun can fire 1,400 rounds a
minute
you
again we turn to the women who are
asking what can I do for defense the
American women's voluntary services
provides instruction in many basic
skills to over 80,000 women soon the
office of civilian defense will
cooperate not only with the aw vs but
with all other private and public
agencies to aid volunteers in obtaining
the training they want a training
indispensable in war valuable in peace
the Red Cross today is the culmination
of the work of a woman who pioneered
under the duress of a war Clara Barton
its founder determined that the care of
the wounded should not be left to the
unskilled today true to its tradition
the American Red Cross volunteers are
responding to the needs of war
distressed people's 25 million and more
surgical dressings have already been
sent to Europe
you
Medical Sciences newest weapon against
death is the blood bank thousands of
women today are giving their blood in
preparation for a day we pray will never
come giving the essence of life to save
life
our history is full of the inspiration
which our pioneer women left us as a
proud heritage and again today American
women are stirred by that heritage
serving their country in the laboratory
on defense production lines in the
civilian defense services and in the
home which is after all the first line
of defense women have always been the
guardians of the home and the children
the future of our country and they are
determined that our democracy shall
survive and that our precious freedoms
shall be preserved